Britain's role in the world regardless
of who is in the government has been in
a good cleaning State for a long time
and still is my opinion and that of a
number of people sort of the government
but it's my opinion as long as they hold
off becoming a part of Europe in a very
sustained way across the whole border
currency and everything they're going to
continue to decline and will be more and
more a small island nature nation with a
big past if they join Europe and we see
an interest in reinvigorating the
European American relationship to be
sort of an entity at the top of the
international system that is comparable
in size both in terms of population and
in terms of economics with a continuing
a rising China and a continuing the
rising India and ultimately a continuing
rising Brazil then they have a future
but it's a it's a multilateral future
it's not an individual future if they
don't do that if they stick with the
Tory government's idea that they should
be hands-off about Europe except for
some things here and there I think
they're at diminishing power in the
world and the idea that there will be a
special relationship in the US and
Britain will begin to faith the more
likely special relationship if there has
to be one between us and just a nation
in Europe is going to be between US and
Germany Germany is once again by far the
most powerful and prosperous prosperous
and successful country in Europe and we
have to keep that in mind as we go
forward now as to whom does this
coalition government represent something
new in British politics they've had them
before but not a long time I think it
does represent something somewhat new
you know the two old parties labour and
the Tories have lost a great deal of
trust and allegiance from the British
public the British public is ready for
more than a two-party system they're
ready for a more European system of a
number of parties and we may see that
begin to flourish even more if this
coalition government is successful